[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم تشكل تجربه الاسلاميه في الجزائر
نموذجا ومرجعا في اتجاهين يعتد بهما لفهم
الحاله الاسلاميه على عمومها في العالم
العربي نموذج الصدام والصراع على اشده
والذي مثلته العشريه السوداء والدمويه
التي شهدتها البلاد في تسعينيات القرن
الماضي يوم وصل الجميع الى نقطه لا عوده
النظام برفضه الاحتكام لقواعد الديمقراطيه
وما افضت اليه الصناديق وما سجلته الرغبه
الشعبيه وجبهه الانقاذ الاسلاميه بتصلبها
وتشددها واتخاذه الخيارات التي ادت
لاندلاع اعمال العنف والتي قضت على الاخضر
واليابس في سنوات مؤلمه عاشتها الجزائر
وهنا كانت الجزائر نموذجا في مساله الصراع
والصدام الذي كان الاسلاميون طرفه الرئيسي
لكنها لم تكن نموذجا في ذلك فقط بل انما
شهدته البلاد وما تشهده اليوم من مشاركه
الاسلاميه ووجود فعال يشكل ايضا مرجعا
للبلاد في حاله التعايش والقبول والحلول
الوسط ضيفنا الليله في الجزء الثاني عبد
الرزاق مقري رئيس حركه مجتمع السلم
المنتهيه ولايته عاش ذلك الصراع بكل
تفاصيله يروي لنا في المقابله جانبا منه
ويلخص جمله الدروس والعبر مما عاشته
الجزائر وتعيشه كثير من البلدان العربيه
اليوم وهو معني ايضا بالنهضه والتحول
الديمقراطي ويسعى عبر منتدى كوالالمبور
الذي يتولى امانته ان يقدم اسلاما يدفع
الى تجاوز حاله الاستعصاء التي تعيشها
بلادنا العربيه من المحيط الى الخليج عبد
الرزاق مقري الامين العام لمنتدى
كوالالمبور للفكري والحضاره العالمي ورئيس
حركه مجتمع السلم في الجزائر لفترتين واحد
مؤسسها ضيف الجزء الثاني من المقابله هذا
المساء فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
اسلاميه دكتور نعم نعم اول في العائله ثم
في الحركه الاسلاميه
نعم نسكن في حي اسمه العرقوب هذا القلب
الثوره في ولايه المسيله في ولايه المسيله
يعني فيه خمسين شهيد تقريبا والاسر كلها
كانت منخرطه في الثوره يعني انا شخصيا
يعني كل اعمامي كانوا من المجاهدين وكل
اخواني مسجلين في وزاره المجاهدين الان
يعني ماذا تركت الثوره في في عبد الرزاق
الطفل في تلك الفتره الروح
الغيره على البلد والغيره على مصالح البلد
لانني انا اعرف عوائل الشهداء مجاهدين كثر
ونشات على حديث الثوره وعلى الاتحاد
الحديث تضحيات فلذلك
مثلي مثل غيري يعني من كثير
تحولت هذه الحاله من تدين العام الى الى
الى نشاط اكثر يعني تفصيلا وعنده في
الدعوه لان في البدايه كانت دعوه
يعني بالضبط في سنه 1974 كنت سنه رابعه
متوسط كان عندنا نشاط كبير جدا في
الثانويه لما
مشينا للجامعه في موقع قيادي في الحرب ما
العنوان الرئيسي الذي كان سائدا لديكم
ابناء حركه اسلاميه في نهايه السفينه
الحزب الواحد معارضه الاتجاه الاشتراكي
اتجاه اشتراكي كجاه علماني في في وجهه
نظرنا وكاتجاه اقتصادي نعتبره بانه ظالم
وغير نافع للبلد
[موسيقى]
الحضارات الكبرى التي نشات في الامريكيتين
ابتلعت لا نسمع لها شيء لانها ابتلعت
الحضاره الغربيه جعلتها ثقافيا لغويا
دينيا من حيث العادات من حيث الثقافه
تخرج من المجتمع تبتلعها حضاره اخرى
بالنسبه للاسلام قيد الله سبحانه وتعالى
لهذه الامه بعد سقوط الدوله مجددين علماء
كبار جمال الدين الافغاني محمد عبده بعدهم
بعد ارشيد رضا الشيخ حسن البنا الشيخ بن
باديس الشيخ نورسي الذين عادوا الفكره
اعادوا وهاج الفكره للمجتمع فتشكل من
السبب بالصحوه
الاسلاميه رجوع المجتمع للدين لان
الاستعمار بعد سقوط الخلافه الاستعمار بدا
يعمل على السلخ الحضاري على الالهاء
الحضاري بالجهل بالفقر
يعني
باشاعه هنا مساله يعني مهمه الاسلاميين او
هؤلاء يعني
علماء النهضه المنقوله هذه الاسماء
البارزه اعاده المجتمع للاسلام لكن ليست
مهمتهم بناء الدوله لا المجتمع هو اللي
يبني الدوله لان كلمه مثل ما قلت لك
الفكره حينما تترسخ في المجتمع
ويتقبلها المجتمع يصبح المجتمع هو الذي
يطلب ان هذه الدوله الاسلاميه منذ البدايه
في محاوله انكار انه هذه الدوله منتج جديد
منتج بقواعد جديده منتج غربي
حديثه اذا اردت الامر لان الامر مهم جدا
يجب ان نفهم ما هي الدوله الحديثه الغربيه
ولكن ولكن في قاعده في علم الاجتماع
المجتمع الغربي لان الفكره اذا رسخت في
المجتمع ستنتقل الدوله حتما حتما مش معناه
ان ان هناك اشخاص او احزاب تريد ان تنقلها
ستنتقل لان المجتمع هو الذي يصنع دولته
هذه المساله
اظن في التباس المجتمع شيء والاحزاب
السياسيه الاسلاميه شيء اخر بمعنى يمكن ان
ينجح يعني ينجح المجتمع في اقامه دولته
وهو مجتمع مسلم ومتدين وبخلفيه اسلاميه
الصراع الذي يعيشه العرب منذ الاربعينيات
حتى اليوم هو صراع الاسلاميين مع الدوله
ومع العسكر ومع الاحزاب السياسيه الاخرى
سواء القوميه وطنيه لما لما مثلا تنظيمات
وجماعات وحركات اصلاحيه تنجح في نشر
الفكره في المجتمع
تتحول هذه الفكره الى ظاهره تتجاوز حتى
الاحزاب والشخصيه المنظمات التي اسستها
يعني حاله الصح وهي اوسع بكثير واكبر
بكثير من الاحزاب الاسلام والحركات
الاسلاميه يعني وكان يعني الاحزاب
الاسلاميه صارت تدفع دفعا من طرف المجتمع
طيب انتم انتم احنا استجبنا لفكرتكم وصمم
متمسكين بالاسلام طيب كيف يستطيع الاسلام
ان يحل مشاكلنا الاجتماعيه كيف يستطيع
الاسلام الذي دعوتمون اليه بهذه الصوره
الحضاريه مش الدعوه للاسلام كدين ولكن
كرؤيا كمشروع حضاري كبير كمشروع مجتمع
ماذا يستطيع هذا الاسلام ان يفعل لي تحسين
معيشتنا لانقاذنا من الظلم لانقاذنا من
الاستبداد انتم دعوه منا ونحن استجبنا لكم
اعطونا الحبل بما انك الامير العام بما
انك الامين العام لمنتدى كوالالمبور
وتجربه ماليزيا تجربه ملهمه عند
الاسلاميين تجربه تركيا تجربه ملهمه هل هل
نجح الاسلاميون بالاسلام هذا ليس حديثا عن
الاسلام كدين الدين العظيم الدين الذي
يمثلنا كلنا ليس حديثا عن الاسلام كدينا
نقصد حديث عن الاسلام كبرنامج سياسي صحيح
لدى الاحزاب السياسيه هل نجح الاسلاميون
في تركيا وفي ماليزيا بهذا البرنامج
سؤال هو الالتقاء
لان مجتمع مسلم معتز باسلامه معتز باسلامه
فمهاتير هو شخصيه اسلاميه ان لم يكن حتى
وان لم يكن ينتمي للتيار الاسلامي يعني
انت لما تسمع مهاتير يتحدث عن الحضاره
الاسلاميه يعني انا بدي لو لو المتابعين
يستمعون للمحاضره القاها في هذا المنتدى
الاخير دكتور معتير يتحدث عن الحضاره
الغربيه كيف ان الحضاره بلا قيم كيف انها
حضاره اوصلت الانسان الى مازق كبيره كيف
اننا نحن كمسلمين لنا حضاره عريقه وكبيره
وتميزت في العلوم وانتجت شيء كبير جدا على
مستوى العلوم ويتحدث حتى عن المشروع
الصهيوني وكيف ويتحدث حتى على انهيارات
الحضاره الغربيه واتحدث عن الشذوذ وكيف
كانت الضغط على على قطر في المونديال وغير
ذلك هذا هو فكرنا وهذا هو كلامنا هذا هو
كلام اسلاميين
كيف هل صعب ان يتم تبنيه من قبل الاحزاب
غير اسلاميه
هذا ليس شرط احزاب اسلاميه صعب نشوف حاله
الامان للمشروع الاسلامي الحضاري الذي
نؤمن به الذي يتجاوز احزابنا ويتجاوز
ويتجاوز يعني منظمات حاله الامل المشروع
الاسلامي هو لما يصبح مفرز مجتمع يفرزه
المجتمع ويصبح التداول على السلطه في اطار
مشروع الامه يعني
هذه رؤيتنا رؤيتنا ان المجتمع هو الذي
يفرز الدوله التي تنتمي للامه تنتمي للامه
الاسلاميه فالذي حدث يعني في الفترات
الاخيره وخاصه الرابعه العربيه ان التيار
الاسلامي بعد ما نجح في الصحوه
ودفع دفعا ليكون في الدوله يعني دفع دفع
هذه الحقيقه يعني لان المجتمع صار بهذا
الموضوع بالطبع اي تيار يصبح عنده حاضنه
اجتماعي سيكون له طموح ليكون في الدوله
هذا شيء طبيعي يعني شيء طبيعي هنا وجد
الاسلاميين الصعوبه هنا وجدوا المشقه
العظيمه في العبور انا عندي اخر كتاب
كتبته اصدار قبل قبل عشره ايام عنوانه
لاستنهاض الحضاري وتحدي العبور الان
الحركه
من الصحوه الى النهضه ومن الدعوه الى
الدوله يعني هذا هو التحدي العبور نحن يجب
ان نسال انفسنا لماذا الحركه الاسلاميه
تجد هذه الصعوبه شيء طبيعي لانها هي لا
تحسن هذا العمل لم تتكون عليه لانها كل
حلقاتها وكل برامجها التي تدربت عليها عبر
عقود من الزمن هي دعويه هي حول العلوم
الشرعيه حول
التربيه السلوكيه حول الفهم العام للاسلام
ولكن لا يقرا الاسلاميون الى اليوم اغلبهم
لا عن الاقتصاد ولا على علم الاجتماع ولا
على العلاقات الدوليه ولا كيف يتعاملون مع
مع الانظمه ولا حتى كيف يتعاملون مع
الاستبداد يعني لا يوجد فكر مؤسس ومؤسس
لدى الاسلاميين فشيء طبيعي ان يجد هذه
الصعود لماذا يصرون على السلطه ويدخلون
المجتمعات في اتون حروب اهليه وتعزيز
الاستبداد وعوده بالدوله الى الى عصور
سابقه وما الى ذلك يعني لماذا هذا الاصرار
طالما ان هذا الامر غير متوفر
للسلطه على السلطه لا شوف اولا هؤلاء شخص
عاديين مواطنين عاديين من حقهم ان يطمعوا
ان يكونوا في الاحزاب وان تكون لهم احزاب
ما الذي يمنعهم هل هم شعب متميز عن الشعوب
العربيه
لا يوجد اشكال لكن سعيهم للسلطه انتج
صراعا دمويا في مراحل كثيره من تاريخ
الامه فيها الجزائر الموضوع متعلق بالسلطه
لو كان التيار الاسلامي هو تيار شيوعي
ولهم امتداد كبير جدا وله شعبيه يحدث نفس
الشيء لان الذين يمنعون الاسلاميين لا
يمنعونهم لانهم اسلاميين يمنعون لانهم
يريدون الصوت في الجزائر في المغرب وكانت
تجربه يعني نهايتها ماساويه سقطوا من من
اكثر من 110 الى الى عشره مقاعد اتيحت لهم
في السودان بالاختلاف يعني باختلاف
بالاشتراك ما بين الاخوان والعسكر
والترابي وما الى ذلك اتيح لهم حكم
السودان لم يحدث شيء يعني لا غير صحيح ان
الاسلاميين يجب ان يتاح لهم حتى يثبتوا
جداراتهم لا يجب ان يتاح لهم يجب ان يسمح
لهم بان يمارسوا حقهم
الان في في مرحله في تدافع في تدافع في
اشياء يصيبنا فيها في اشياء يخطئون فيها
وهم الان بصدد التاسيس لمسار نظري جديد
لانه في الحقيقه الذي يحدث هو التقاء بين
صروره تاريخيه وحتميه نص
السيروره التاريخيه هي مئه سنه من الكفاح
النظام منذ بدايه ظهور الحركات الاصلاحيه
منذ اواخر عشرينات وثلاثينات القرن الماضي
الى هذه المرحله نحن نتحدث على سنه الحركه
الاسلاميه حققت اهدافها بنسبه عاليه جدا
جدا لانها حينما نشات حركه في تلك المرحله
كان لم يكن
هدفها القريب والسلطه صحيح في رؤيه
البعيده هي الاستناد الحضاري ولكن هدفها
كيفيه ارجاع الناس للدين يعني
مرحله فقه الدعوه مرحله الصحوه واستغرقوا
فيها الامر ونجحوا فيه نجاحا كبيرا الان
انتقلوا الى مرحله جديده
فقه الدوله هذه السيروره التاريخيه تلتقي
مع حتميه نصيه وهي قول الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلم يرسل الله على راسه كل مئه سنه
لهذه الامم من يجدد لها دينها فاذا نحن في
مرحله تج ديد
بمعنى ان اندفاع الاسلام للاستنهاض
الحضاري الذي يمر حتما بالدوله حتما
بالدوله وحينما نقول حتما بالدوله نحن لسه
من ذلك الصنف الذي يتمسك بالسياسه وبالحكم
ولكن هذا مسار
سامحني هذا الانتقام نحن بصدده يعني هذا
التدافع وهذه الاخطاء التي تقع التي ذكرت
اخطاء طبيعيه لان الحرف تجرب في شيء جديد
ولكن هذه الاخطاء الاخطاء كلها ستدخل في
رصيد الفكر وفي رصيد التجربه ولا شكه ولا
شك ان التيار الاسلامي ولما قلت التيار
السرور بهذه الاسماء الموجوده ليس
بالضروره
حضاريه كبيره يعني سيظهر فكرا جديدا
وسيظهر توجهات فكريه جديده وسيضبط المنهج
وستنتقل الفكره الاسلاميه للدوله
وتنهض الامه الاسلاميه باعتزازها بامتها
باعتزاز
اذا كانت الحركه الاسلاميه انجزت كثيرا في
فقه الدعوه كما كما وصفتها هناك ثمه فكره
تطرح تطرح حتى من قبل الاسلام الا ربما لا
يملكون الجرعه على طرحها في العلل لكنها
تطرح وخاصه فيما يتعلق بجماعه الاخوان
المسلمين في مصر جماعه الرئيسيه والتي
اثبت الطوال سته سبعه عقود عجزه لا نقول
فشلها فشل والنجاح هذه مساله تقييم تحتاج
الى امور كثيره لكن عجزها عن تحقيق الهدف
السياسي في الوصول الى السلطه لماذا لا
تحل مثل هذه الجماعات الاسلاميه
والاسلام موجود في المجتمع وموجود في في
كل نخبه وفي كل تياراته وتصبح مساله
النهضه هي مساله تتعلق بالمجتمع وليس
بوصول حزب او تيار سياسي اسلامي محدد الى
السلطه لهذا الذي كنت اقوله اولا حق
الاخوان المسلمين
لم يفشلوا في تحقيق الهدف الذي اشتغلوا
عليه في العقود الماضيه الهدف الذي
اشتغلوا حليقه حقيقه هي الدعوه لم يشتغلوا
الهدف الهدف السلطه يعني عبر عقود
المنافسه على الحكميه في هذا الثلاثين سنه
20 سنه الاخيره يعني ولكن ولكن هدف الدعوه
تحقق فيه نجاح كبير جدا هم الان دخلوا في
مسار جديد في هدف جديد وهو المنافسه على
الحكم انت حينما تنافس على الحكم ستجد صدا
وستجد صعوبات كبيره ويتعرض المجتمع لايذاء
شديد بسبب رغبتك انت للسلطه فلماذا لا
تعفي المجتمع من هذه الرغبه المؤذيه
والمدمر حتى وان كانت الطرف الاخر مستبد
انا لا اقول
له السبب الازمه هو الاستبداد انا كنت
اقول لك وهذا يعني جازما حتى وان كنا
شيوعيين نطلب الحكم ولنا حاضن اجتماعيه
سنضرب ستقع يعني
الحلقه الماضيه حينما تحدثنا عن الجبهه
الاسلاميه للقذ وحينما طرح بعض المتطرفين
منها انه العنف والخيار الوحيد لانكم
حينما شاركت بالسياسه تم الغاء الانتخابات
بعد الدستور 88 و89 والانتخابات والغاء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه
اذا هذا السلوك يستخدم كحجه وانتم قبلتم
بهذه الحجه قلتم نريد ان نكمل بناء الدوله
وشاركتم جزئيا وخطاتم جبهات الانقاذ هذا
يطرح اليوم انه نعرف ان هناك استبداد
فلماذا تطرح يعني يطرح الاسلاميون انفسهم
كاداه للاستبداد حتى يتغول اكثر في هذه
المجتمعات ويمارس عنفه ويمارس تنكيله بها
ليش نكرر المشكل والاستبداد يعني سواء كنت
اسلاميا اذا طلبت السلطه ستضرب الاستبداد
هذا يعني وقع في امريكا اللاتينيه وقع فيه
وقع لعقود طويله من الزمن في افريقيا وقع
لعقود طويله في
اوروبا الشرقيه وقبل ذلك حروب طويله يعني
بين بين القوى السياسيه في اوروبا الغربيه
نحن نتحدث على حرب 30 سنه من
دول نتحدث على حروب دامت مئه سنه هذا ليس
خاص بالطياره الاسلامي يقع تدافع على
السلطه هذا شيء طبيعي عادي ليس خاص
بالاسلاميين هل الانقلابات التي توقعت في
افريقيا كان فيها اسلاميين هل الانقلابات
والهيمنه والسيطره التي كانت في عهد
الشيوعيه كانت يعني بسبب السمين هل ما حدث
مع
معته هل كان سببه لا غير صحيح هذا التدافع
على السلطه ومن حق الاسلاميين
ان
يطلبوا تطبيق برنامجهم
فاذا هناك فرق كبير بين الاسلاميين كاصحاب
فكر وكاصحاب برنامج
وسبب الصدام سبب الصدام ليس لانهم اسلاميه
لانهم يطلبون ان يطبقوا برنامجهم وبحقهم
وفي كل الاحوال هذه المرحله ستزوم وسيجد
الاسلاميون طريقهم وستعرف الشعوب بان ثمن
الاستبداد كبير جدا جدا
[موسيقى]
قبل نحو ثلاثه عقود
ظهر مصطلح الاسلام السياسي ليقصد به بشكل
مباشر السعي نحو السلطه والحكم وهو هدف
تتساوى فيه الاحزاب ذات الصبغه الاسلاميه
مع غيرها
وعقب احداث الربيع العربي التي اندلعت
شرارتها اواخر عام 2010 استفاد الاسلاميون
من رصيدهم التراكمي في العالم العربي ومن
ثم تمكنوا من الوصول الى سده الحكم في دول
عده قبل ان يتقهقروا سريعا في كل من مصر
وليبيا وتونس والمغرب وغيرها خلال السنوات
الممتده بين عامي 2013
لكن وفي مقابل سقوط حركات الاسلام السياسي
عربيا ثبت كثير من احزاب هذا التيار دعائم
حكمه في بلدان غير عربيه ذات ثقل سياسي
واقتصادي والديموغرافي على غرار تركيا
وايران وماليزيا في مفارقه تستحق التوقف
عندها مطوله
وفي تفاصيل تعثر تجارب الاسلام السياسي
بالعالم العربي سيقت اسباب كثيره لكنها
تفتقر في معظمها الى الموضوعيه ذلك انها
ظلت اسيره مبالغه فريقين الاول يحصرها في
زاويه الافشال بفعل مؤامرات الثوره
المضاده والاخر يختصرها في عدم اهليه
التيارات الاسلاميه للحكم المنشود
في تركيا هناك تجربه لافته وشهد التحولات
عده حتى وصلنا النسخه العداله والتنميه من
ايام اربكان وحزب الرفاه والاحزاب الكثيره
التي الغيت من قبل العسكر والاستبداد وفي
نهايه المطاف استطاع الاسلاميون ايجاده
تسويه ما عبر الايمان بالعلمانيه والاقرار
بها والالتزام بقواعدها في ماليزيا هناك
تجربه نجح نجح التيار نقول اسلامي عبر
مهاتير محمد
في ايران نجح الاسلاميون الشيعه في قلب
النظام وفي اقامه جمهوريه اسلاميه وفق
الرؤيه الشيعيه الجعفريه
الكل نجح الا العالم العربي الاسلامي
العرب الا يبدو امرا لافتا
عربي
كبير جدا
لاسباب عديده اولا هذه الدول الاستبداديه
اغلبها ليس كلها هي هي منتج الاستعمار
يعني هي
دول علمانيه كثير منها
له سند كبير من قبل الاستعمار
تركيا عاشت حاله استبداد التي يعيشها
العالم العربي لمده اكثر من 80 سنه يعني
يجب ان لا يجب ان ننسى يعني العالم العربي
الصدام بين التيار الاسلامي
والحكومات هو اقل من حيث عدد السنوات مما
وقع في تركيا يعني تركيا عاشت نفس التجربه
عاشت الصدام والانقلابات لا ننسى ان
الاستاذ اربكان يعني تم الانقلاب عليه
وتعرض للمنع يعني عده مرات كان النظام
يسمح كل من ربي اعاوده الاسلاميين بشكل
جديد وبتهذيب اكثر انا اقصد الان خلينا
نرجع السؤال الاصلي لماذا نجحهم هنا وهناك
ولم ننجح
المسار متقارب ليس بعيدا لان لما تحسب
بعدد السنوات تاع السودان بين الاسلاميين
في الشان السياسي والانظمه العربيه هو
تقريبا نفس عدد السنوات اللي وقع في تركيا
وقع في امريكا اللاتينيه وقع في اوروبا
الشرقيه وفي افريقيا وهي نفس الظاهره نفس
الظاهره لان في مرحله ما كانت الدوله
القوميه العلمانيه وحدث الساحه يعني
معناها بالعكس كان هناك صراع بين بين
التوجه الاشتراكي والتوجه التوجه
الراسمالي في العالم العربي لم يكن لم يكن
الاسلاميون في المعادله السياسيه هذا
معروف يعني يعني الدوله الدوله القوميه ثم
الدوله الوطنيه كانت صراع بين اليمين
وكانت هناك عن امريكا ودول تابعه الاتحاد
السوفيتي فاذا الدخول الاسلاميين في
الصراع هي يعني دخول جديد يعني الاستعصاء
كان من قبل كان من قبل ما يبرز الاسلاميون
في المنافسه على الحكم كان هناك صراع يعني
لا ننسى ماذا حدث من صراعات يعني سجون
واعتقالات في حق في حق اليسار وفي حق
العراق صحيح في سوريا كل الناس بصوره
مختلفه في المغرب ايضا نحن لا يحمل المسلم
هذول
وبشكل القمح يعني بمعنى ان الاسلام دخلوه
في وضع جديد
ثم هناك مساله اخرى يعني وهو ان المنطقه
العربيه منطقه مهمه جدا للغرب والامريكا
بشكل خاص اكيد الاهميه هذه بدات تتراجع لو
كان عندنا الوقت نتحدث عن الامر هذا الذي
سيكون
صحيح صحيح سيكون له تاثير كبير لصالح
الديمقراطيه غير اسلاميه المنطقه العربيه
منطقه مهمه جدا من حيث الموارد شوف انا
اطلعت على وثيقه اعطاها للشيخ محفوظاح
وانا كنت شاب صغير في عمري يعني 31 32 سنه
استلمها من السفاره الامريكيه مكتوب فيها
بالنص حرفيا بان الاسس التي تعتبر فيها
امريكا
دوله صديقه ولا غير صديقه هي ثلاثه
اسرائيل
مصادر الطاقه
والاخلاق الديمقراطيه الديمقراطيه حقوق
الانسان
فلذلك جماعه المغرب قبله باسرائيل
تمرر من خلاله كل شيء لماذا تسمح له بان
يعني
ابدا
جزاره سفير امريكيه في يوم من الايام قالت
لي بصراحه مشكلتنا نحن مع المسلمين هو
البديل يعني مشكلتنا فيقراطي قلت لها
امريكا والغ مش صادقين في قضيه
الديمقراطيه في ذلك الوقت قلت لهم انتم
مثلا
تدعمون لا اريد ان احرجك الاسماء على كل
حال تدعمون هذه الدوله وهذه الدوله وشوفوا
مستوى الديمقراطيه وقضيه المراه كيف موجود
وكذا
من اجل الابتزاز قالت لي بالحرف الواحد
احنا مشكلتنا في البديل اذا توقفنا عن دعم
هؤلاء من البديل بدر الاسلامي يعني قال
السؤال الاصلي هذا السبب الموقف الغربي او
الموقف الامريكي تحديدا والغربي حجر عثره
امام تحول ديمقراطي في العالم العربي ومنع
الاسلاميين من ذلك مقارنه بتركيا وماليزيا
ماذا ايضا ماذا فعلهم كي ينجحوا
بالطبع كل كل بلد له مساره التاريخي مع ان
ايران دكتور ايران يعني ايران ضد اسرائيل
على الاقل علنا بشكل واضح
وبالنفط ايضا يعني اختلفت
وفي الحريات مختلفه مع الامريكان ونجحوا
ايضا فيها السياقات التاريخيه تساعدها
مهمه جدا يجب ان ننتبه بان اثناء صعود
اثناء صعود الخميني
كان هناك دعم من طرف الغرب يعني حتى
الخميني نفسه يعني معناها كان هناك اراده
لفهم المنطقه واعاده تشكيلها يعني وبعدين
ايران في الحقيقه اثناء صعودها يعني كانت
هي السد المنيع في مواجهه العراق الذي كان
صديق الغرب يسار خطر يعني فكان هناك كانت
هناك لعبه امم لعبه امم
معادله
والامريكان يعني يشتهون ويحسنون التعامل
مع التنقل التناقضات طيب دكتور
عقائديه انشات من ثوره يعني لما وصلت
الثوره
هذا الموضوع يعني الثوره يكون التيار
الديني فقط كان هناك تيار الديني متحالف
مع تيار علمان ولكن بعد ما نجحت الطلب
عليهم كليه
احنا دائما لما نتكلم مع الاسلاميين دائما
يذكر الغرب كحجر عثراء الموقف الامريكي
الاستبداد واثره يعني تذكر عوامل خارج
اطار الاسلامي حدثنا وانت يعني دكتور صاحب
تجربه هامه سياسيا وفكريا عن العلل
الداخليه في العلل الداخليه الداخليه
كبيره يعني ما في ذلك
اول اول عله والعله الفكريه اول اول عله
يعني كثير من الاسلام لم ينتبهوا بانهم
صاروا يمارسون عملا لا يقراونه ولا
يتدربون عليه يعني مثل واحد تقول مثلا انت
تشوف يافطه في كليه هي كليه الطب ولكن
داخل الكليه يقرؤون الكيمياء والفيزياء
يعني شيء اخر يعني يعني الاسلاميون اندفع
المنافسه على الحكم ودفعتهم مجتمعاتهم
حواظن ومجتمعيه ضخمه التي جاءت من خلال
الصحوه دفعتهم المنافسه للحكم ولكن ليست
لهم ادوات الفكريه يعني الاسلاميون لم لم
يقراوا ولم ينتجوا ولم يتدربوا في كيفيه
التعاون مع تناقضات الحكم يعني ولذلك
الصب الكبير الذي وجدوه امام الاستبداد
اختلفوا في التعامل معهم هناك من اندمج
داخل المنظومه الحكومه واصبح جزء من الحكم
المستبد والفاسد وهناك من بقي في صدام مع
الحكم على كل حال نحن في حركه مجتمع السن
طورنا يعني فكره جديده وهو نحن نحافظ على
سيادتنا وعلى استقلاليتنا ولكن لا نصادم
الحكم ولا نقبل ان يبتلي عنه ولا نقبل ان
نتجه وناجحين منزله ما بين المنزل ولكن
مكنتنا من السير لانه صادم الحكم لان
مصادم الحكم في مصلحه وليست في مصلحه
البرد ولكن لا نسمح له ان يدمجنا او ان
يدجننا لا نسمح له وبالتالي احنا مرتاحين
جدا جدا ونحقق لنتائج كبيره يعني على
مستوى الانتخابات على مستوى المجتمع على
مستوى شبابنا على المستوى الحركه
الاجتماعيه يعني على مستوى الحركه الفكريه
يعني في حاله استقرار كبير جدا يعني
فالاسلاميون اذا عندهم مشكله فكريه كيفيه
التعامل مع الاستبداد كيفيه التعامل في
النظريه الاقتصاديه كيفيه التعامل مع
المجتمعات المعقده لان اثناء الدعوه كانت
التعامل مع المجتمع البسيط انت داعي عندك
خطاب تعطيه للناس جميعا خطاب ديني يتوائم
مع كل الفئات ومع كل الشرائح ولكن لما
تدخل للسياسه هنا تجد بان المجتمع معقد
يعني الشرائح تختلف حاجات الناس تختلف
ضغوطات الناس تختلف ان لم تفهم المجتمع
على اصول علم الاجتماع وتعرف مؤثرات
المجتمع لا تستطيع ان تمارس السياسه
ممارسه الدعوه غير ممارسه السياسه كذلك
العلاقات الدولي كيف تتعامل مع الناس كيف
تتعامل مع امريكا كيف تتعامل مع الصين
يتطلب لان الحرك سميع جايه من من
عقائديه الدينيه في بعضها مطلق ولكن لما
تدخل السياسه يصبر تصبح تجد نفسك في حاله
لا يوجد فيها الاسود والابيض فقط يعني اذا
هنا فيه ازمه فكريه ثم بعد ذلك فيه ازمه
ممارسه الاسلاميون لم يمارسوا من قبل الذي
يمارسونه اليوم يعني
الغريب
نعطيك نعطيك مثال يعني وقع في منتدى احنا
كل الايام كانت فيها الافتتاح ثم
المحاضرات النظريه ثم دراسه التجارب ثم
بعد ذلك ادخلنا في الورشات وكانت هناك
اربع ورشات ورشه المشروع السياسي ورشه
المجتمعي ورشه التطوير الاداري والتنظيم
وشريعه البعد العالمي الاغلبيه الساحقه من
واحنا قلنا لهم متوزعه على الورشات كما
تشاءوا الاغلبيه السياسي بمعنى ان الحركه
كثيرا يعني
تلك الحواضر دفعتها للعمل السياسي وهي
اصبحت تنافس على الحكم
وهي ليست لها خبره فصارت تقع اخطاء كثيره
في الممارسه ايضا في مشكل في الممارسه
فيها مشكل في المناهج في المناهج العمل في
المناهج التغيير اين يقع مركز القرار هل
يقع مركز القرار في القاعده في القاعده
السياسيه يعني الحزب السياسي ام ان مركز
القرار هو في الجماعه من الذي
يقر الجماعه او الحزب العلاقه بين الدعوه
والسياسي صارت فيه هناك يعني مشاكل تتعلق
بالاداره تتعلق باداره الوظائف بالطبع
اشتغالهم الكبير جدا بالعمل السياسي خلاهم
يخرجوا من فضاءات المجتمع ويضعفوا في
المجتمع المدني بالرغم انهم كانوا هم
اسيادهم كانوا هم اللي موجودين فيه كثير
فاذا الحركه يسمى عليها ان تعيد الانتشار
على اساس فكره وعلى اساس تطوير المناهج
والتطوير الاداري وكذلك على مستوى القدره
على التعامل مع الاجيال طيب قبل ما يجب ان
تقوم به قد يكون يعني حساسيه في تشخيص
ملفات خارجيه يقصد ولكن تجربه الاسلاميين
في مصر هي الاكبر والاهم بحكم حجم مصر
تقييمك لما جرى في 2011 حتى 2013 ما هي
ابرز الاخطاء التي ارتكبت على مستوى
السياسي ليست هي التجربه الابرص بل ربما
هي من التجارب المتخلفه جدا يعني التجارب
الابرز في العمل السياسي الموجوده في
الجزائر موجوده في المغرب موجوده في
موريتانيا موجوده في الكويت موجوده في
اليمن يعني هذه الحركات الساميه دخلت في
المنافسه السياسيه واستطعت ان تكون موجوده
في المجالس وان تكون في الحكومات يعني
تطورت كثير لان الصد في مصر كان قويا
لاهميه مصر بطبيعه الحال وخصوصيه النظام
السياسي العسكري المصري بخصوصيه المجتمع
يعني السماح للاخوان بان يدخلوا في
الفضاءات الممارسه تخلف على هذه الدول
فلذلك ليست التجربه
السياسيه الاخوه المسلمين في مصر على
مستوى الدعويه الابرز على مستوى الدعوي هي
الابرز في هي المدرسه مع المسؤول السياسيه
المتخلفه جدا استثمارها 2011 حتى انتهاء
الارض هذا هو المشكل ولذلك لما لما بعد
الرابع العربي والاثناء الرابع العربي وق
ع السياسيه كبيره جدا ابرزه يعني ابرزها
ان الاخوان المسلمين
تخلفوا في دخول الثوره هذا الشيء طبيعي
لان اي كتله كبيره جدا لتتخذ صعب وبعد ذلك
لما تكون احداث وتحولات كبيره في الشارع
يعني لا تندم بعد ان تفهم ماذا يحدث ولكن
حينما دخل الثوره حسموا ابطال معركه الجمل
كما يقولون يعني
خرجوا من الثوره قبل الوقت هم لما يعني
اسقاط مبارك بداوا يعني في الحوار يعني مع
المجلس العسكري وفي اعتقادي يعني هذا هذا
خطا في الحق كان المفروض ان المرحله
الانتقاليه لا يسمح مش اخوه وحدهم فقط لا
يصح بان تكون في يد العسكر فقط
الانتقال الديمقراطي علم يسمى
الانتقال العلم يدرس في الجامعات الانتقال
ينجحوا حينما يكون تكون مرحله للانتقاليه
التوافقيه تكون فيها كل الاطراف المفروض
ان الهيئه التي تسير المرحله الانتقاليه
يكون العسكر جزء منها فقط ولا يكون كلها
انت لما تعطي المرحله انتقاليه او تسمح
بان تكون مرحله انتقاليه كلها في يد
العسكر بكل تاكيد هو الذي سيعيد بناء
المرحله الجديده على مزاجه وهو الذي يؤثر
في التشريع وهو الذي ينقطع القواعد وانت
بعد ذلك ستجد نفسك في ارضيه لا تتحكم فيها
فالاخوان المسلمين خرجوا من الدائره كانوا
فيها الاقوى وهي الربيع العربي
وهي ميدان التحرير فوجدوا انفسهم في مساحه
خطيره وهي رابحه حينما كانوا في مدى
التحرير كانوا في وسط الشعب كانوا مع
الشعب في سلك يصعب ضربهم
لا يمكن ضربهم يعني
جدا ولكن حينما ذهبوا وحدهم في رابعه يعني
كما قال احد المفتين يعني ضد الاخوان يضرب
في المليان يستطيع تضرب في المليان يوم
كتله واحده وتضربهم يعني انا في اعتقا
انتخابات الرئاسه كان بتقديرك خطا كبيرا
عادي
كلها مقدره
للمرحله الانتقاليه شوف انا انتقل
الديمقراطي درسنا عليه وانا عندي بحث يسمى
الانتقال الديمقراطي تجربه ميدانيه
واشتغلنا عليه كثيرا مع الاحزاب في
التنسيقيه حريه الانتقال الديمقراطيه لمده
ثلاث سنوات الانتقال الديمقراطي الحزب
القوي الحزب القوي اثناء الانتقال من
مصلحته الا يكون في الصداره من مصلحته ان
يترك الغير يشاركون في المرحله الانتقاليه
لحتى لا يتحمل المسؤوليه وحده لان
المجتمع بعد الثوره تكون تطلعاته كبيره
تكون مطالبه كبيره والوضع ماساوي والوضع
ماساوي وانت عندك اغلبيه
ومستقبلك يعني معناه يعني في الحق يعني
مضمون تقريبا انت المفروض ان لا تتقدم الا
تكون في ولكن تكون صاحب قرار ضمن اصحاب
القرار يعني فاعتقد يعني كان المفروض يكون
عندهم حرص كبير جدا يعني ان لا يتقدم
وخاصه على مستوى الرئاسه لا سيما وان
الاخوان كان عندهم قرار جازم ان الحركه
الاسلاميه لا تشارك لا تنافس على الرئاسه
يعني احنا مثلا لما دخلنا في الانتخابات
في 95 كان لهم شديد علينا من الاخوان
المسلمين في مصر لان الشيخ ترشح انتخابات
تاع 95 فكان عندهم لهم شديد على الشيوخ
المفروض الحركه
لا تنافس على الرئاسه لانه كان عندهم راي
شديد بان الحركه الاسلاميه اذا كان فرصه
للتوافق جيش التوافق افضل يعني يعني
المنافسه تكون حينما لا يكون فرصه للتوافق
يعني فهم في الحقيقه يعني دخلوا
الانتخابات الرئاسيه ربما لو استطاعوا لو
استطاعوا يعني ان
يدخل انتخابه لكن اضمن لهم واضمن لمصر على
كل حال نحن نقيم الخارج هم ادرى بشؤونهم
من الداخل
لا عندك راي لا في الدكتور انه تقول انه
تجربتي النهضه في تونس والعداله والتنميه
في تركيا والمغرب ليست تجارب اسلاميه
منشوده هي يعني مرحله
المشهود المنشود المنشود ان نكون في مستوى
التطلعات العالم الان
الشعوب في العالم تبحث عن بديل اخر اكثر
عدلا ورحمه اليوم الناس
يشهدون الماساه التي
يحدثها هذا النظام الراسمالي
بالفلسفه النيه والليبراليه الذي ينشر
الفقر الذي يجعل عدد قليل من 63 شخص
يملكون ثروته عدد ثلاثه مليار من البشر
هذه الحروب يعني هذه الماساه هذه الفروق
الاجتماعيه الكبيره الاعتداء الكبير على
البيئه الامراض اذا الناس يبحثون عن بديل
جديد نحن نزعم انه عندنا بديل عندنا بديل
هذا البديل يقوم على اساس اقتصاد المشاركه
وليس اقتصاد الربوي
لان سبب الازمه هو اطلعت على على بحوث انا
عندي مكتبه كبيره جدا في الاقتصاد واغلبها
باللغه الانجليزيه والفرنسيه يعني
علماء كبار غربيين يقولون بان سبب الكوارث
في العالم هو الربا هو اصلا الازمه
لرسالتي تاع الماجستير يعني هو حول حول
الازمات الاقتصاديه في العالم ازمه البيئه
والتنميه والدكتوره حول حول ازمه 2008 سبب
ازمه العالم هو الاقتصاد النبوي نحن
اقتصاد الذين نعرضه هو اقتصاد المشاركه
ليس اقتصاد الربوي الحاله الموجوده اليوم
في تركيا او اقتصاد ولكن نحن لا نلوم
بطبعه الاتراك ولكن هذه مرحله
يعني الذي يتيح الفرصه
للمشاركه في الربح والخساره هذا هو يعني
يعني هذه النظره الفكريه الفلسفيه الكثيره
جدا التي يجب
اشياء شبيهه بالبنوك الربويه يعني ولم
تقدم اقتصادا اسلاميه هي لا تستطيع حلول
ومعالجه اخرى لانها ليست ممكنه يعني اليوم
مثلا البنوك الاسلاميه حتى في الاقطار في
الدول الاسلاميه تحت قوانين الربويه يعني
مثلا انت لم تغير قانون القرض والنقد مثلا
ان لم تجعل خصوصيه لهذا البديل في علاقته
بالبنك المركزي لا يستطيع ان يتطور يعني
البنوك الاسلاميه تحت البنوك وتحت منظومه
الاقتصاد العالم فهي اذن تندفع لتجد لها
مساحه وهي تنمو تكبر تحقق نجاحات كبيره
جدا فهي لا تشتغل في البيئه اللازمه ولكن
هي مرحله من مرحل يعني انت انت لا تستطيع
انك
كاتب مقال مهم جدا في هذا الكتاب تاع
الحضاري بان البناء الحضاري لا يقاس بعمر
الانسان يقاس بعمر الامم يعني لا يمكن ان
تتصور بان الحضاره الاسلاميه ستكون في
مستحيل يعني حتى وصلت الى القلق الحضاري
يعني
لاننا وصلنا او شرفنا على النهايه يعني
بمعنى ان التجربه الموجوده في تركيا هي
مرحله من المراحل يعني انا في الحقيقه في
البدايه كنت اعتقد بان اصل الفكر
الاقتصادي عند الحكومه عدله والتنميه هو
فكر راس مالي غربي ولكن حضرت مؤتمر
فاتغير يعني راي فيهم تماما يعني حضرت
مؤتمر كانحضر في الاستاذ اردوغان والعديد
من الوزراء
فتمتعت بما قاله يعني اولا في المؤتمر
الايات الاولى تاع القران في المعطيات
كلها تتعلق بالربال انا قلت على هذا واحد
الشيخ متاثر يعني حب يدخل عليهم في هذا
الموضوع فاذا به الخطاب نتاع كل وزاره الى
اردوغان هو ادانه كامله فكريه وثقافيه
وسياسيه للنظام الربوي العالمي
والافق هو الاقتصاد فقلت
رؤيا لا تلام
على عملك في هذه المرحله ولكن حينما لا
تكون لك رؤيه انت مندمج في رؤيه الاخرين
طيب دكتور شرفنا نهايه الحلقه انكسار
ديمقراطيه نشهدوا في العالم العربي انكسار
الحضاري تخلف عن الركب وانكسارات اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه اخرى متفائل متفائل جدا
متفائل جدا لانني حينما قرات التاريخ بان
رايت بان ما يحدث لنا ما يحدث للامم اخرى
متفائل لان حينما انظر خلف قبل ثلاثين
اربعين سنه
اتذكر بان الام كانت تائهه تذكر بان
الاسلام كان غريب نحن كنا غرباء حقيقه انا
اذكر لما دخلت الجامعه الاستاذ علي في
1979 في الجامعه بكاملها كانت محجبه واحده
اليوم الجامعات والسنويات والمدارس
الاغلبيه الساحقه نساء محجبات ملتزمه
بمختلف اشكال الحجاب لان شوف
في ثقافتنا الاسلاميه هناك ثقافه العليا
هناك الثقافه السفلى لما نتكلم مثلا عن
اللباس الثقافه العليا هو الستر الثقافه
السفلى كل امه تلبس كما تريد المهم الستر
كما تريد نحن من اولئك المتشددين الذين
يريدون يعني توسيع وعولمه نمط لباس معين
يعني في بلد لا المهم نتكلم على الاكل
مثلا الثقافه العليا هي الحلال بعد ذلك كل
ما تشاء الافغاني اكله ليس ليس كالسعودي
والسعودي ليس اكله كالجزائر والجزائر ليس
الافريقي ليس الماليزي فاذا الثقافه
العليا
هي الستر يعني ولذلك لما نقول لك انا اصبح
الان الناس كلهم محجبات في اطار ثقافي
متنوعه يعني ليس بالنمط تاع الحركه
الاسلاميه اذا كذلك يعني في في دراسات تدل
على ذلك الدراسات دراسه دارت الامم
المتحده على الاقتصاد دارو استطلاع في
العديد من الدول العربيه يسالون
المسلمين ماذا تفضل التعامل
المالي الربوي
ولو
بفائده بمصلحه اقل او التعامل الاسلامي
بفائده قالوا انا تفضل التعامل الاسلامي
ولو بمصحه اقل الاغلبيه الساحقه يعني
بمعنى الامه متجهه الاسلام الامه متمسكه
بالاسلام ويجب ان ننظر الى هذه الحاله ليس
من خلال من خلال ثقب الاحزاب الاسلاميه
لا من خلال يعني الفضاء الواسع للاسلام
هذه امه تستوعب الاحزاب الساميه ولما
نتكلم على الحضاري يعني رواده وفاء
وفواعله ليست الاحزاب الساميه فقط هي
شخصيات هي علماء هي فنانين هي ادباء هي
شعراء هي دول كذلك هنا يعني حتى بعض الدول
العلمانيه وتساهم في الاستئناف الحضاري
يعني نقول لك مثلا هل هل هل
المواقف تاع الحكام تجاه الاسلام هي نفسها
التي كانت في السبعينات والان لا يعني
كانت العلمانيه غليظه في ذلك الوقت يعني
كانت العلمانيه شديده يعني
شرسه الان صار الحاكم لكي يستقر في حكومه
يظهر بالمظهر الاسلامي ويحط امامه المظاهر
الاسلاميه اذا الاسلام الاسلام يتقدم لو
نتحدث مثلا
اللي هي مؤشر اساسي في مستقبل الاسلام
يعني لو الانسان يكون يوسف يقول ويحب يكون
متفائله اكثر من اللازم يقول يعني ليست
بعيده اولا المقاومه لم يستطع احد قهرها
رغم الحصار ورغم الالام لا تزال يعني اصبح
اصبح توازن رعب موجود رغم الفرق الكبير في
التسلح المجتمع الاسرائيلي يتفكك بشكل
كبير جدا لان المجتمع الاسرائيلي يعني
تشكل من خلال توائم كبير بين بين
الصهيونيه العلمانيه وبين
الصهنيه المتدينه الان فيها يعني شرح كبير
بنصه المتدينه والصهيونيه العلمانيه فا
الامل كبير جدا ثم بعد ذلك ازمات العالم
شوف لما نقرا مثلا ما يكتبه ابن خلدون او
ما يكتبه او ما يكتبه مالك بالنبي عن
صعود وسقوط الحضارات يعني
لما لما يشرح ابن خلدون على
في اطواره الخمس واجيال الخمس عن فتره
زوال الحضارات وكانك ترى الحضاره الغربيه
مجسده فيما يقوله ابن خالته لما تتكلم
مثلا تقرا ما يقول
الحضارات تموت انت تموت انتحار وليس قتلا
ويقول سبب انهيار الحضارات هو حينما تتخلى
عن القيم الاخلاق مالك يقول نفس الشيء
يقول لك مرحله الروح ومرحله العقل ثم
مرحله الغريزه الحضاره الغربيه طغت فيها
الغريزه بايدن يمضي على فرض الاعتراف
بالزواج المثليه في كل الولايات الامريكيه
ونحن نرى ما وقع في ما وقع في في قطر يعني
ان الغرب اصبح مش فقط انه يعني
يسمح بانتشار المثليه في بلاد يريد ان ان
يعلمناها على العالم باسره الغرب يفقد
معالمه الغرب الذي نشا يعني في حتى فتره
القرن
الوسطى في زمن النهوض الكارولينج على اساس
ديني كانت يعني كلها يعني في اطار ثم بعد
ذلك وقع الصدام مع بين العلم والكنيسه
وابتعدت الحضاره الغربي عن الدين ولكن
اليوم فقط ابتعد الدين ابتعدت على الادميه
ابتعدت عن الفطره فاذا كل هذا يجعلنا
نتفاعل بان المستقبل المستقبل لهذه الامه
علينا ان نخرج من هذا الصراع على ان
اسمعني
ويعني ان ناخذ الصراع ونبحث عن المساحات
المشتركه بيننا نفهم بان مصلحتنا جميعا في
ان نتفق على عقد اجتماعي ونحل مشكل الحكم
بالحريات وبالديمقراطي الحلقه بالتفاؤل
بهذه
الخاتمه المتفائله دكتور عبد الرزاق مقري
شكرا جزيلا لك على وجودك معنا في حلقتين
شكرا شكرا لمشاهده الكرام على طيب
المتابعه القاكم ان شاء الله الاسبوع
المقبل في حلقه جديده في امان الله الف
شكر يا دكتور شكرا
[موسيقى]